what is bitcoin
Bitcoin is a software and it's a
distributed software to operate the
peer-to-peer Network between members who
are all equal on the network they're all
peers and what this software does is
that it allows you to operate a payment
Network between those peers and that
payment network has its own currency
and that seems like you know just a
simple software game but the reason this
is such a big deal is I believe Bitcoin
is the most advanced form of money ever
invented and the reason for that comes
from two properties that this network
has the first one is that the currency
is the hardest money ever invented is
the money whose Supply is the most
resistant to inflation it's the first
monetary asset that we've ever invented
that is guaranteed to be fixed in its
Supply that cannot be increased Beyond a
certain number so there's only ever
going to be 21 million Bitcoins and
that's that's a that's a qualitative
Leap Forward in our Technologies of
money all of our monies leak essentially
because people can always make more and
more and more of them you know the best
money is the one that leaks the least
which is gold because it only leaks one
and a half percent in other words your
share of the Gold stock is diluted by
one and a half percent every year
ideally you'd like it to be zero Bitcoin
is currently at around 1.8 percent
headed towards zero so it's the first
money that we've ever had that goes to
zero in terms of terminal Supply so
there'll never be more than 21 million
Bitcoin I think that's a huge deal
because you know as I said earlier money
is always whatever is the hardest to
make and now Bitcoin is the hardest
thing to make and then the second
property which is extremely important as
well is the fact that it operates
without the need to trust in anybody it
doesn't have a party that is in charge
of it it doesn't have a central
Authority that can
um you know it's as I said it's
peer-to-peer so there's it only has
users it doesn't have any admins there's
no Authority in charge of Bitcoin that
can take your Bitcoin that can stop you
from using Bitcoin uh that can change
the rules of Bitcoin they can't make
more of it so it's fixed it's available
for anybody in the world it's the
hardest money ever invented and it is
absolutely uh I think an an enormously
enormously significant invention because
um if you read the Fiat standard and the
Bitcoin stand as well you'll see my
perspective for why I think a very large
number of problems on the world are
caught in the world are caused by easy
money are caused by installation
and caused by government having access
to essentially an infinite uh recourse
to people's wealth and I think Bitcoin
fixes this because it allows us to have
money that has the sustainability of
gold across time meaning it holds its
value across time like gold but much
better than gold but also it has similar
to it is similar to Fiat and that Fiat
can travel quickly but Bitcoin can
travel even faster than Fiat so it
combines gold stability across time with
Fiat salability across space in one
immutable package that nobody can change
and nobody can control can you define
the word sellability sustainability is
the essential property of money it's the
ability of a good to be sold easily on
the market specifically to be sold
without much loss in its value so houses
are great for living in but they're not
very salable if you want to sell a house
you can just click a button and sell
house and have a giant market of people
buying houses from you you need to find
you need to find somebody who wants the
exact house that you have with the exact
specifications that you have and because
you know houses are not identical
there's no liquid giant market for
people to just buy and sell identical
houses from
um so gold for instance has uh good
salability as money
because it's a liquid good that's
uniform and people are always buying it
Fiat dollars have great sellability
because everybody's always buying and
exchanging dollar for other Goods so if
you have a hundred dollar bill you can
easily get rid of it and you'll get a
hundred dollars worth of stuff for it if
you have a hundred dollars worth of
stuff it's harder to get rid of it if
you have 100 worth of phone it's not as
easy to spend it as a hundred dollar
bill that's salability what do you mean
that Bitcoin I understand that Bitcoin
is the sellability of gold across time
better even yeah better yes like on the
order whatever
um and then and then it has a celebrity
of Fiat across space what does that mean
so if you remember when you asked me
what is the advantage of Fiat what is
the advantage offers us it's it's
cheaper to move Fiat across space than
it is to move gold you know with with
the current Fiat monetary system for all
of its flaws you know you can send money
uh you know I could send money from my
bank account in the US to a bank account
in China in a couple of days or in
Britain in France in a day or two which
is you know much faster than you could
do with gold and much cheaper than you
could do with gold
but in reality with Fiat you know the
reason Bitcoin improves on that is that
with Bitcoin you're actually selling
you're you're sending final settlement
in a couple of hours
so you send the Bitcoin transaction you
get six confirmations in an hour you get
about 12 confirmations in two hours on
average with 12 confirmations you know
you're pretty
um definitely clearly safe on this
So within a couple of hours you could
send the billion dollars across the
ocean and
have final settlement on them it's not
just that you've sent a credit
obligation that's going to need weeks
and months to settle which is the case
with Fiat
so it is faster than Fiat effectively so
it's harder than gold and faster than
Fiat
that's good way of putting it